Hey everybody uh it's 2023 and I really
really wanted to send out a positive
message at the beginning of the year but um
recent events have made that impossible um
don't get me wrong I loved spirited it's it's
great maybe we had a blast the entire family
watched it I love will I love Octavia obviously
I did the greatest showman with with benj and
Justin they're incredible and I loved their
music uh and good afternoon by the way the
song Good afternoon I laughed the entire way
through it is absolutely brilliant however
just heard the Academy have shortlisted
good afternoon in the best song category now
Ryan Reynolds getting a nomination in the best
song category would make the next year of my
life insufferable it would I mean I have to
spend a year with him shooting Wolverine and
Deadpool and it trust me it would be impossible
it'd be a problem so but just to recap love
spirited love will love Octavia love the
song Good afternoon love benj and Justin
but please please from the bottom of my heart
do not validate Ryan Reynolds in this way
Welcome back everyone happy New Year always
a good day to see Hugh Jackman just making fun of
Ryan Reynolds and teasing Deadpool 3. they just
released another promo making fun of each other
also revealing the official title of the movie
we found out exactly how they're going to explain
Wolverine during the movie as well how he becomes
part of the story in what Deadpool does to get him
involved in the adventure so we'll break it all
down be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we've got another major Ant-Man in the Wasp
quantumania trailer video coming next week
we'll see more footage of Kang the Conqueror modok
who's going to be another big character they're
introducing in the MCU and they'll begin filming
Deadpool 3 really soon as Hugh Jackman jokes about
during this movie like I'm gonna have to deal
with him all year long while we're filming this
movie so we'll be getting a bunch more footage of
that soon too and of course I'll be doing videos
for everything the clip I put at the beginning
of this is part of a long-running gag that Ryan
Reynolds and Hugh Jackman have had for like the
last many many years since they've been friends
for a long time promoting each other's stuff in
really funny ways just making fun of each other
but secretly being good friends the difference
in the past six months or so with the way that
they make fun of each other and videos like
this is a Hugh Jackman signed on to come back
as his Wolverine for the fox Marvel movies for
Deadpool 3 in the MCU so them making fun of each
other has been more specific to promoting
Deadpool 3. before that they've been doing
videos like this making fun of each other is a
backdoor way just to Hype each other's movies
for years like I said one of my favorite is when
Ryan Reynolds bought the aviation gin brand and
Hugh Jackman just ripped him a new one really
yeah wow um I I'm not quite ready to show my
name but let's just cut for a second no it's not
almost finished just some color correcting for a
second let's just roll it come on go go go roll
it roll it Ryan Reynolds is a complete and total
the gin's pretty great though
I'll have to try it someday
sorry man I didn't think the truce was actually
real it's all in jest if you couldn't tell
immediately like they're best friends they've
been doing this as a joke for a long time before
Deadpool 3 started development they were just
promoting each other's movies back when the Logan
movie came out a couple years ago Ryan Reynolds
did the same thing making fun of Hugh Jackman
Hugh Jackman also helped him promote Deadpool
2 when that came out that's where this video
came from the marketing campaign for the first
Deadpool movie is still one of my favorites hello
I just saw the most anticipated movie
of the year Deadpool it was glorious
once in a generation a movie comes
along that your whole family will love
if your family is a put up group of kissing
inbreds they're going to be posting Deadpool 3
videos like this throughout production this year
and next year the Press tour for this movie is
going to be amazing but buried in Hugh Jackman's
video making fun of Ryan Reynolds here and some
of their tweets reacting to his video you may
have recognized that he revealed what the actual
title of the movie is going to be and it confirms
a couple of our theories in the video Hugh Jackman
refers to it as Wolverine and Deadpool and in his
Twitter reaction Ryan Reynolds says that he does
not approve of the name change just confirming
that the title of the movie will be Deadpool and
Wolverine they were never gonna call it Deadpool
3 but there was a question as to what kind of a
subtitle they might go with like Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe because they're doing a
version of that story from the comics for the plot
not exactly the same comic book story because it
is pretty crazy but that's why I've been making
jokes about Deadpool kills the fox Marvel Universe
because Kevin feige recasting a lot of the X-Men
the Fantastic Four characters inside the MCU so
what better way to give the fox Marvel movies
a big send-off and honor them and make fun of
them a lot canonizing them through the Multiverse
just like they did with Toby Maguire's Spider-Man
movies Andrew Garfield's Amazing Spider-Man
movies and Spider-Man no way home and then
proceed to do a version of Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe but just have him destroy or
mess with the fox Marvel Universe I've done a
couple videos about how Deadpool 3 is going to
be a huge Crossover with the Loki series because
the TVA Mobius and Miss minutes are going to be
big characters in the movie here's how they're
explaining Hugh Jackman's Wolverine in the movie
as well as pulling off a bunch of the fox Marvel
movie cameos with older actors coming back to play
their characters again like OG Fantastic Four
actors more Classic X-Men actors coming back
the movie is meant to be a direct continuation of
the events of Deadpool 2 where Deadpool ended the
movie taking Cable's time travel device visiting
several points in his timeline as well as other
timelines changing the past like killing a variant
from his own timeline the original weird looking
version of Deadpool and Wolverine Origins
he killed over version of himself in another
timeline before he made the Green Lantern movie he
messed with Baby Hitler and they're just going to
say that he continued messing with timelines
in the fox Marvel Universe until eventually
he tries to save a younger Wolverine from dying
earlier in his timeline like before the events of
the Logan movie but one day your old pal Wade is
going to ask you to get back in the saddle again
when he does say yes and that's how Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine becomes part of the plot when they first
meet they fight like Deadpool vs Wolverine
or Wolverine vs Deadpool however you think
about it Hugh Jackman's been revealing the plot
just joking about how his Wolverine can't stand
Deadpool as you would expect they talked about
this in their big teaser video last year but part
of the joke of the characters like The Comedy of a
Deadpool movie with Wolverine is that both of them
have crazy healing factors so they would just
be able to lay into each other chopping every
bit of their bodies off and healing it almost
instantly so the fight would just go on forever
eventually the TVA detects all the changes that
Deadpool is making to the timelines he's causing
so much Havoc destroying the timelines the TVA
Mobius Miss minutes come after him and that's
how they get involved in the plot that's how they
explain this is a Marvel movie because those are
core Marvel characters now in the MCU I don't know
if Tom hiddleston's Loki will also have a cameo in
the movie because they're supposed to have so many
different cameos in the movie but while Deadpool
is jumping around in his timelines that's how
they feature feature a lot of the cameos from
the old Fox Marvel movies like they're supposed
to have cameos from the original Fantastic Four
movies I don't know which characters are
supposed to come back right now there have
been rumors about Chris Evans coming back as his
Johnny Storm he said previously he would love to
do that it's only coming back as Captain America
that he's kind of reticent about they were gonna
have Fantastic Four cameos in Deadpool 2 but it
was the original version of the movie back when
Tim Miller was still directing it and it would
have been the Fantastic Four characters from the
newer reboot version and when Hugh Jackman says
they're not touching the events of the Logan
movie because they're jumping around timelines
what he's implying is they're just gonna say
that the events of the Logan movie took place in
a distant future of an alternate timeline I know
there's going to be a billion questions about
how timelines work in the MCU versus alternate
universes like is an alternate universe the
same thing as an alternate timeline the way
they explain this in the Loki series is that
like a major timeline like the sacred timeline
he who remains timeline is actually a collection
of many smaller timelines woven together kind of
the way that a rope is actually a collection of a
bunch of strings woven together within the sacred
timeline even though it was meant to be a single
timeline there were like subtle variations where
you have different timelines where things are
just like a little bit different but not that
different and they'll be saying that Deadpool is
jumping around in a timeline that's just specific
to the fox Marvel Universe with a bunch of subtle
variations in minor timelines within it so that's
how they explained the original Deadpool here in
the newer Deadpool the Old Man Logan Wolverine are
all from the same Fox Marvel Universe but within
that they come from different timelines the only
time alternate timelines become fully alternate
universes is when Nexus events are created like
when they do something so crazy that a Nexus event
happens and gives rise to a dangerous Kang variant
I'm sure I'll have to make another video on this
when the trailers for the movie start coming out
it's not nearly as complicated as it sounds but
we'll be talking about it again too when Loki
season 2 comes out those episodes will release
in the early summer so well after Ant-Man and
the Wasp quantumania will have already seen a
version of Kang the Conqueror so actually now
I'm starting to think that the version of
Kang that we see in Loki season to is yet
another variant because if they're planning
on saying that another kang variant will be
a version of the beyonder in secret Wars from
Kang the Conqueror like another variant I'm
also assuming that we're going to see a bunch
more variants of Kang there were some Easter
eggs for the Rama Tut version of Kang during the
Loki season 2 trailer but they haven't released
that online yet I've already done a full video
for it because it was in the d23 trailer you can
click here to learn more about that and click here
for that scene of Spider-Man meeting a version of
Wolverine thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!